if you are 22 years old you are entering
first of all some of the greatest years
of your life a but B this this is the
moment this next five year window is
when you don't go practical and safe
this is not the time to get the job Mom
wanted you to this is the time to
realize that you have a five-year window
and it's three for some it's eight for
others but this is a five year window
for you to attack the life that you want
to win this is the best and easiest five
years of your life because this is when
you need to attack what you love and
what you want to do here's why you don't
have all the baggage you get to live
life one time and this is the time right
now to understand what's actually
happening and actually map your behavior
to something that will impact you for
the next 80 years boy if you're lucky
enough to be graduating today with not a
[__] idea of what you're going to do
with your future nobody's ever been
luckier than you please recognize it